good morning ladies and gentlemen my
name is kian
and i am from what is design a
collective of design students
discovering design
from a student's perspective we share
about the value of design in today's
context
and we and we encourage you to
participate in singapore's design
movement
i'm kian and i will be your even emcee
and moderator for today
thank you for taking time to join us
this webinar today local design board
games
the first of the what is design series
of talks
our topic today is on board games and
gamification
from creating one in the midst of a
pandemic
to leveraging in gamification methods to
anticipating possible problems when you
want to put this into practice
the session today is presented in
collaboration with national vending
gallery and design singapore council
with the support of national design
center
this event is also part of the national
design centers program
line up in august and september with a
thematic focus
on singapore our home and before we
proceed
i would just like to highlight a few
housekeeping rules should you encounter
any technical issues
please feel free to reach out to our
technical team
through the zoom chat function we ask
for your patience and understanding
should conditions
be less than perfect during this webinar
your audio will be on mute
however we welcome your questions
throughout the presentation
via the zoom q and a function so when
you pose a question
please remember to first state your name
and company
and also if you have a specific panelist
whom you would like to respond to your
question
do indicate so as well finally please be
informed that this session will be
recorded
now please allow me to introduce the
panel and this morning's program
first we have yasmin keda co-founder of
bye bye virus a card game
that aims to bring some cheer to people
stuck at home
and teach them how they can protect
themselves against viruses
yasmin will be sharing a video
presentation on how designers start
their ideation process
next we will have ziolai co-founder of
capital gains studio
and mercat games xeo has published
award-winning edutainment board games
which have won the highest accolades in
international series play awards
he will be sharing a video presentation
on how to recognize the value in a card
dim idea
and when to move on from project
failures last
but definitely not the least lydian lee
founder and creator of say what
a fun card game to learn languages while
playing she will be sharing a video
presentation on when
and how to use gamification and solving
problems
lillian has background in advertising
design and user experience
she believes strongly that gamification
on learning or any skills learning is
important
we will then be wrapping up things with
a live
q and a session with all of our
presenters so please feel free to post
your questions throughout
the presentation via the q a module
also poll questions will also be
appearing on your screen
after each video presentation to further
guide our discussion
so please participate and let us know
your thoughts
without further ado i will now present
to you
yasmin cater and the link slims
presentation that
explores how designers start their
ideation process
it will be an insight into the ideation
journey
hey you and welcome to five lessons from
creating game
my name is yasmine and i'm one of the
co-founders of the awesome game called
bye bye virus
so before we dive in i want to share
with you why people don't start making
games and oftentimes
it's because there is a fear of failure
of what's going to happen when i go
ahead and create anything
it's only apply for game that applies
for just about anything
people don't start doing things or we
use excuses like i don't have enough
experience
or i don't know where to start and the
reality is
that when i look at any creative
endeavor i look at it as an opportunity
as a journey
and i want to have a lot of fun in it
and then i also look in terms of not
having enough experience as
well if i don't have enough experience
right now how do i get more experience
and maybe i can ask some people who know
a bit more to help me along the way
and that's why please don't be afraid to
ask for help because
most of the time people will help you
it's really incredible i'm going to
share with you examples of how people
helped us in developing this game
and if you don't know where to start i
think it's a really steady
reason people say is because we live in
an era where there's google
and google has just about anything we
developed a game
with no experience googling just about
everything from the thinking process
and so forth and of course the second
time i make a game would be better
but it was a good starting point and
then from there we just keep on evolving
so a bit about me is i started an onto
my entrepreneurial journey
as a teenager and not because i had that
entrepreneurial streak in me
it was because my father lost his job
and for three years he was unemployed
and my
family was using family savings so the
environment was a little bit stressful
so my mom really said if you want
something you have to go figure it out
so i started creating lots of things i
sold paintings i made jewelry
all kinds of things so i could make sure
that i had the funds i needed to do
the things i wanted to do and most of
the time those
those sales were helping me get more
learning and more teaching
in the in the creative world so when i
ended up working in my career i ended up
at the very beginning starting in the
oil and gas sector
and um my father unfortunately had
passed away from cancer
so i got certified as a coach and at one
point i was generating
more revenue from my side business and
my real business
who made me realize that i would rather
do much more meaningful work in this
world than to go ahead
and to to work an environment not
inspire me
so since then i ended up going ahead and
training thousands of entrepreneurs to
become more effective at selling
themselves
and at one point in this journey i ended
up launching a production agency
even though i had no experience making
videos and took it from
zero to a million dollars within 18
months and now
what i focus my attention on completely
is the sales story method where i train
leaders entrepreneurs on how to go ahead
and sell through many of my different
programs
so when covet hit you can imagine a
training business that predominantly was
offline
was severely hit so i ended up going
into my google drive
and really finding this game that i had
developed
four years ago i had developed designed
everything was ready
but i was so scared to put it into the
market and
within 10 days when covet hit i launched
the game
i made a small order i made an order of
200 decks and i printed it in singapore
and brass pasta
so all very local and i realized
wow like when i got customers giving me
feedback
how much i loved it and it really opened
up
more opportunity of what can be done as
a different tool for education
so during this time as well denise and i
ended up brainstorming a bunch of things
that we could do in case
my business would tank basically because
of what was happening with covid
um so we ended up writing a roadmap of
how to make a million dollars and all
these side hustles
to be able to help us along the way and
we were really naive obviously because
making a product does not take a month
somehow we thought it would just be boom
a month when we already have our own
jobs or businesses
so something that we learned as a
mistake but from that we ended up
picking one game and then boom
this is one of our prototype versions of
by virus we predicted it during circuit
breaker and it was on a really shitty
paper
we printed two different colors and one
of the colors you couldn't even read the
text it was so bad
[Music]
so you might be wondering why a virus
game well
it's pretty simple we looked around us
and everyone's talking about
kovid and we said why not it's a it's a
good time to make it
make a game and a viral thing would be a
cool idea
but since then i've actually identified
like seven or eight
different games that i want to develop
and i think it's once you
start with what's something that you
care about with me you're passionate
about
you discover more opportunity and that's
the reason why i think the singapore
dream
is so successful is because it's making
fun of the fact that we're always
talking about the singapore dreams
and we never had a way to describe it
and they
they put in a way that's just beautiful
so for us we're like okay
everyone's talking about a virus how can
we make it in a way that it's it's
contextually very
very there and initially our target was
to go ahead and develop it for kids so
we
try to make it quite educational and
then we discovered during one of our
prototype nights and actually when
adults play the game
it becomes a drinking game because
adults can make anything into a drinking
game
but the lesson that i start off with you
is the first thing i learned
making a virus was this the first
version
is really and we ended up taking
paper
and cutting it out we didn't even think
to buy like a flash card we just bought
this and did that
and it would scribble on but what
happened is
it just gets better and that's why my
mantra for anything that i do anything
that i do as any project i always think
this is a shitty first draft
and it literally is in my head and right
now bye bye virus
is on the 73rd shitty first draft
and it's a draft that i'm really proud
of but then i let go
of that attachment to that it is going
to fail it's going to be horrible
because it's just an evolution
and one of the things that we did
obviously it was tests we tested not
only in terms of
the game but the game dynamics we tested
also in terms of
why are cards rectangular why are they
not square and then we discovered it's
hard to actually
shuffle them so we discovered a lot of
things around it
which was really really really crucial
and as we got along the journey
guess what the ideas evolved and they
got better and our shitty first draft
got nicer and nicer
i even got to the level where i was like
i don't want to make i want to make sure
that
our characters are both female and men
uh equal as well as people who are just
people who don't identify to either
gender
so it was just like thinking about it
and evolving the thinking to make it so
inclusive
because of what was happening and what
was the
condition around black lives matters i'm
like oh my gosh we don't think about
these things but i want to show that we
are thinking about not only
race but also gender as well
and along the way we made a ton of
mistakes
and that's why i love the mistakes the
mistakes are all lessons of learning
like one of our biggest mistakes is you
should always develop a game
with a name in mind and then you develop
everything else after that so it's all
under
like that message but what happened was
we ended up developing the game and
discovering
at the very end like actually what we're
gonna call this thing um
so we ended up starting off by listing
out the worst ideas ever
from uh kill corona to coronita
or you're dead like so silly ideas
but from that list we got a list that we
liked more
um and then from there we picked not
only the name bye bye virus
but we also found the name of our next
game which was going to be coming out
next year called free the grannies
now along the way one of the things that
we learned
was that maybe it was locked down maybe
a circuit breaker but we were saying yes
a lot more
um and to give you an example one of the
things
we decided because a friend inspired me
to do this it's like you should put on
kickstarter
like how are you going to cover the cost
of the game and we're like oh yeah it's
true
but we had no experience with
kickstarter so we had to make a video
and after trying and getting frustrated
by the fact that we were stuck in these
four different walls
what happened was uh he started making a
rap song
and it wasn't that bad and then we got
it a bit better
and i was working on getting ar vr
filters
for our instagram and facebook for our
characters
and then we decided and our video became
a mixture of both
which was to be honest quite terrible
but quite fun that we went ahead and was
able to do that
and the fifth lesson that i learned is
that the reason why we were able to
launch a game in 10 weeks
is because a were a tiny bit insane but
b is because we asked for lots of help
when we were doing the rap video a
friend of us
a friend of ours knew someone who's a
rapper called masha1
who actually has written lyrics for
jennifer lopez and then
my friend's boyfriend is an educational
specialist specialist so i
can like basically accepted him to
knowing about
instructional design and learning about
that and even
his sister janice and this is only three
out of the dozen
dozen people will be asked for help so
in case you're looking at doing
something please ask for help
you might know a senior you might know a
friend you might know a teacher
you might know anybody who can go ahead
and do those things and help you
and because of the help one of our
friends jian and assaf who are
in pr helped us draft the press release
and
and taught us how to go ahead and pitch
to press and from there we got fish on
the straight times on a
whole full page uh which was fantastic
but not only that we were also like
trending on straight towns
upside for a couple of days which is so
amazing
so it's just incredible from that shitty
yellow paper we were able to create this
this game is actually one of the test
prints that we had
but not only that uh as part of the
process as well we were very inspired
about helping
more families and obviously we have the
clients who buy our games but what about
people who can't afford it
and as a result of that we were able to
apply for financial grants
and now distributing over a thousand
decks to at-risk families
and going to be impacting 4 000 lives
all because of that one
silly day in february where we're gonna
head
thinking about this crazy idea now
it is an incredible journey but it's
also a
really scary as i mentioned earlier on
and on friday we actually received
all um our decks
and imagine paying somebody over
ten thousand dollars and
never having seen the product and just
having to trust
that it's gonna be okay after hearing
some quite horror stories
but we did our due diligence we reached
out to people who had worked with this
factory
and we just hoped it was the best so you
can imagine when we finally opened it
and the cards were perfect
how much joy that was and actually i
cried a lot
when it came on friday because i was
like i can't believe it's finally here
and all these people are going to
actually get it as well so with regards
to our journey so far
we've been able to conceptualize it
within a week
we go ahead and develop a mvp within two
to four weeks we went ahead and tested
and iterated for
have for like two weeks as well we went
ahead and launched the campaign
and took us about eight weeks of
printing for phil and now we're in the
focus phase
moving forward on distribution and
partnerships so
we're very lucky uh we're starting this
game right now on lazada you can buy it
by vibration mazada also the national
design
center they have a vending machine you
can buy it as well so that indiegogo
and we're looking to be into more shops
more environments
more communities where they actually
people are promoting games
because that's the next chapter that we
have to deal with and they're all things
that we had no experience on but that we
were doing and re-evaluating and going
ahead
and from letting go of that fear to
trying we were able within
like four weeks of launching you know we
made a rap video we had
hated on our ads on facebook we
generated
within five weeks over 57
which is kind of mind-blowing
considering the fact that
we're always learning these things
thank you yes me and denise for your
insights into how we can translate game
ideas into reality
we hope that presentation gives you a
rough idea of how to commercialize
and kick start your own game project
let's take about half a minute here to
hear from the audience
a poll should now be appearing on your
screens
with the question when attempting
something new
which of these thoughts bother you the
most let us know
what you feel hinders you at the start
of an ideation process
okay we see the results coming in right
so it seems like
the most popular choice is insufficient
experience
and you know sometimes we think that
we're so new at this and you know
there's always someone that's better
than us right
so you know it's important as part of
our lives to learn from our failures and
you know constantly challenge ourselves
so that we can grow and learn
next we will now be sharing zil lai's
presentation
where he will share more on the ways to
recognize failures during game design
process
and how we can move on from there
hi good day my name is zio and i'm the
co-founder for caprica studio
so we have published board games in
singapore such as uh
debzilla cryptocurrency and mongamine
and we have distributed all this game
around the world in u.s europe and
different parts of asia and
we have won some awards uh particularly
for cryptocurrency and that's enough
so today i'd like to share with you a
bit about why to volcanoes here
so over the years as a publisher we have
talked to many game designers who
couldn't get their bot games created
into a form and bring to the market so
why do they feel
let's discuss more about that so firstly
the question is
is it rap mechanics design uh in a way
partly so if it's a
bad mechanics that basically breaks the
game or makes the game
unplayable of course i don't think you
can sell the game you'll probably
dump that out way before you want to
publish the game but however
what if uh for some people they feel
that bad mechanics is like
not creating new innovative mechanics or
copying your mechanics
for somebody is it necessarily bad when
you try to duplicate
some mechanics from other people i would
say that
yes and no you when you try to borrow
some mechanics from people you try to
create some innovation yourself
and i'll say that one of the good
examples that i have here is against
humanity over here
uh what the cast against humanity do so
they basically uh
duplicated most of the mechanics from
apples to apples the episode
has a similar format whereby you have a
question and you put answers and you
vote
for the theme mechanics however it's a
much more of a family-based games
whereby the question answers are not
much more family friendly well cast
against humanity
is much more edgy and goes against the
norm but
for some reason i guess uh people prefer
satire over more family fund
cause against humanity as sells very
well also thanks to their very good
marketing
and they actually did better than apples
to apples okay then the other thing is
lousy hour and team so some some
designers feel that you know you need to
have great hard work
in order to attract people to buy your
game that is somewhat true
but then again let's look at the cards
against humanity as an example if you
look at
artwork uh that is literally no i would
it's just what's text
simple fonts and just blank background
wells look at on the right side you have
citadel
which is also one of the very famous
game with beautiful artwork that
probably costs a few hundred usd
for single illustration so the thing
here is that
cars against humanity does better in the
mass market while citadel does better in
the
gamer market so what do mass consumers
prefer so they maybe prefer more edgy
more jokes or else either they prefer
better game plays and prefer better art
so at the end of the day whatever that
you create the important thing is to
create a game that the market
wants okay and not what you want okay
the problem with a lot of game designers
is that when they
design again of course it's designed a
dream game that they want and often they
play among their friends
which typically have the same kind of
likes however whatever you like may not
be what the market wants
so importantly is to bring the prototype
out to the market and that is to let
them see what they want
and what kind of artwork do they want
when they look at this game
okay the next thing is of course
execution execution execution
uh just now i mentioned that a lot of
the game designers
their ideas died in their dream so they
have either they threw it out
but they didn't execute so the most
important thing in
a board game project to make it
successful is to take action
as a queue and to kill executing okay so
there's three form of execution the
first one is product execution
where you when you design a product you
do prototype testing
you create a prototype you test your
friends your test with
strangers to test until that you nobody
can have any bad comments about you
and then you are ready for the next
stage which is operational execution
this is the part where you find someone
to try to manufacture your
your game try to find artists to draw
out your dream your
the kind of team that you want and of
course uh get the goods
over to the different countries in this
case try to ship to singapore and
when you store it how do you sell it how
do you deliver it to your distributor
how do you deliver it to customer
okay so all these things are fine
details that many game designers do not
really
take care of until the the hits the
wall and when you have a bad
customer experience this is the part
where a lot of people have bad
experience with
lastly is the marketing execution uh
when you have a game you cannot just
leave it on the shelf
okay so a lot of the distributors when
they talk to us
they are telling us that you know a lot
of game designers when
after they design a game they pass the
game to us and
they just think that you're fire on the
shelf it doesn't go this way you need to
have a lot of marketing support behind
whether you're running events
you're running conventions you go on the
media to talk about games
or this is part of the process of
selling the game and help the
distributor so
once the distributor hears that you are
actually helping them actively market
the game
they are also more willing to help you
take your game onboard
so uh what are some of the things that
we have done so far actually
you see what camera gains has done we
actually go out there we go to different
media around the world
talk to them to get them to feature our
game
talk about the game and whether it's on
facebook on the newspapers
or on a blog or some cryptocurrency the
last one is interesting
it's actually a cryptocurrency uh
quarter that uh prices about
cryptocurrency they talk about the top
five cryptocurrency games
you should try and of course ours is uh
quite highly recommended over here
so the thing here is that you need to go
out there and talk and tell people about
our game your game doesn't just
sell on its own so the next thing is of
course
sales and marketing uh importance and
marketing okay so when do you persist
uh in the game so there are some
designers asking me you know zero i've
been working on this game for a couple
of years
i can't seem to get it correct should i
continue or should i just grab the idea
and just start on with what other other
ideas
so uh i would just like to share a a
story
uh from saboteer this game called
saboteur
the the designer actually had quite a
challenge
when first trying to market this game to
a publisher
so what happened was that he approached
more than 12 publishers
and most of the of course all these
child publishers rejected him
reasons for rejection through boring
mechanics is similar to another game
or the game is too simple so
by the 12 times you know most people
discourage but for him he approached the
13th publisher and this
is a german publisher called armyco and
what happened after that was
you know he didn't have overnight
success i mean the story didn't end that
way
the game's so okay but one year later it
was being done at five euros
at warehouse so they thought that's it
the game is dead but however what
happens next was
the game later picked up later and it
became one of the most popular games
around the world
so the thing here is that the story is
that block games takes
time to build the attraction takes time
to
spread the word so you need to let it
have time okay so
you cannot just hope that you have
become an overnight success like some of
the blogging projects because they have
been designed by
famous designers or what uh as a
newcomer you expect to spend a lot of
time
and effort to promote your game so when
do you stop
okay sometimes you need to stop because
things such as
financial affect you creating a bulkhead
is a very expensive venture
there's always a job in your industry
saying that the best way to 1
million dollars on board games is to
throw one million into it okay so that
is the
that's how you make money so when you
aren't unable to
uh where your problem with your daily
expenses please stop
and take a step back save up again
and then come back and relaunch again
okay mentor so sometimes creating a
board game
is very stressful whether it's an art or
it's operational problem you know a
factory screw operating you become very
stressed
or sometimes you just cannot get a
breakthrough what do you do okay same
thing
take a step back and talk to people and
see
how the best way that you can go on and
lastly is life priorities of course
things like health is important
uh things like maybe you have a new you
just got married have a new baby or
maybe
your parents just for sick and these are
important aspects you shouldn't neglect
them because
there's a saying that health is wealth
and wealth is what games
so remember one of the important thing
to create a bargain is of course you
need more
or money so we have no wealth and you
have no health no wealth and no pockets
okay so that's that's how i have to say
okay so what do you do when you
encounter setbacks okay
uh you have to first determine which
phase are you stuck in where and who can
you help find
how to identify the problems and do you
need additional results where to refine
the resource
okay so one of the biggest uh resource
trove out there is this uh
site called bob james gig it's basically
like a key video of what gives
almost every blockage in the world is on
bobbinski and it has a huge
forum and community made of designers
publishers and producers that can give
you
uh they are very very free to share
whatever they know
it with you if you do ask and of course
you have stole my gifts they design
a very famous game such as wingspan and
psi
and the founder has a very big block
that talks about
his design processes marketing and
distribution process
so check that out these two sign out and
i'm sure that you'll get some
inspiration from
these two sites okay so i think that's
about the end of the thing so how do you
become a successful
game designer okay the most important
thing i would say to new designer
especially is to play mobo games
i find a lot of game designers they play
games that are dated or that is not
no longer popular the mechanics of team
is no longer popular
they are not playing the latest game
that being launched so if you want to be
a fashion designer you need to
you know look at the latest uh design
that's being launched if you want to
design a board games that appears to do
this crowd you need to start playing
board games has
been recently launched and of course
research is a challenge
there have been a lot of buggers around
there in the world with stories behind
where the founders probably share how
they succeed
look out for the stories and i'm sure
you for your insight into how we can
evaluate the value of a card
game design so we hope that this video
gives you a rough
idea of how to access when to take on a
game idea and to develop it further
let's take some time again here to hear
from the audience
a poll should now be appearing on your
screens with the question
what is success to you how do you define
a successful well-designed game
will also take about 30 seconds okay we
have votes coming in
keep going let's have a look at the
results so
it seems that most of us actually about
half of us
see success as being able to see
families having fun
playing with it okay so if you have any
questions for
zeo as well remember to leave it in the
q a module
um in our next segment we can look
forward to
learning how to apply game mechanics to
successfully enhance
engagement in our everyday activities
and learning
so last but not least we will now share
lilian's presentation
where she shares her thoughts on when
and how to use gamification
hello everyone my name is dillian lee
and i'm the founder and creator of saver
and everyone might be thinking what is
say what about
okay say what is created based
on the lack you know and the resources
of learning
chinese dialects or any other languages
you know in a fun manner
so we came up with this idea why not
make
learning fun and why not we make
learning languages
all a local culture in a fun manner so
that people can embrace it easily
without being it to be much more of a
like you know so-called educational in
classroom or you need to read to
understand about certain
things you want to learn so in the
beginning when we started it we did a
lot of user tests
and tested on friends and also like
family
and people who's interested in learning
languages and
what happened is like um it started with
ideal human-centered design and from
this the brief we came up with what we
can do for the community
and it was a passion project from the
beginning
and when we did that i never
ever expected to be like you know um
being a product that can sell well in
retail outlets and also online
and in the beginning when i started it
was just a small little booth
in maad design that is on dot design
museum
which is just a style but after that
when we got two more retailers then we
realized
maybe you can expand it more to more
like shops and also like you know
bookstores
and from this like thinking like can we
expand it out of singapore itself
so a little bit back to the history uh
how we created it we created we started
out with
actually um cantonese card games
and from there uh we started with uh
coffian after these two cards that is
cantonese and hawken
um we got a an audience from the crowd
who is
someone from uh overseas asked like how
about singlish
tara we did singlish itself yeah
and english is quite good with a lot of
like tourists and people trying to
understand what singaporeans are
speaking like you know
is that english or is that some kind of
like singlish card game
and from english card games of course we
did not stop there
we went to uh create more cards you know
for people to learn language
and we realized like mandarin or chinese
is actually considered
the most toughest one so we did
something like you know what
if someone who doesn't speak chinese who
doesn't understand chinese culture
nothing at all
how do we make them to learn chinese but
in a fun manner
and we created a lot of time like tones
is easily being embraced
for someone who doesn't understand
chinese so plus we created mandarin
menu card games and from mandarin um
people are asking like hey sometimes i'd
love to go to jv
or uncle indonesia but is there a simple
phrase that can speak
even basic indonesia and bassam nayu
there are something that is similar but
at least like you know if you get the g
star of it you will understand so we
created passive value card games
and this is actually quite a good
product that is doing very well in
malaysia for
people who visit malaysia and wanted to
learn simple phrases
and of course we created ourselves um
japanese card game
okay and korean type game you know which
i worked with uh samsung
if he's a korean teacher yeah
so the uniqueness of these three cards
is actually japanese korean and mandarin
is actually um i collaborated with
illustrators and also like you know
we're thinking like you know how do we
like bring these illustrators
out of just singapore you know and by
like you know
if anyone's who orders this in the u.s
or in uk at least
they know that oh who's this you know
unique illustrator i'm gonna find out
more about it or maybe there's
collaboration
you know across the country in the world
now uh
go straight to what is important for
today we'll talk about like
learning through gamification and why is
it so
important imagine
every one of you you went through school
can you tell me one thing
is studying in school the most fun thing
that you ever had and like you know
you're telling your parents like you
know
hey i want to do homework i want to go
to school today
i want to like you know sit in the
classroom morning till afternoon
listening to all the subjects you know
unless you're really a bookworm or a nut
you might like it but other than that
um i just felt that you know learning
you know is not the most fun thing you
just need to learn because you need to
pass and get grades and continue your
life and find a good job
but what happened if they make learning
through gamification
like imagine when you're at a home
playing board games
you do learn about monopoly about like
how to conquer certain kind
of like you know property certain
landmark but that is learning but
you'll feel it like it's an education
that you need to sit down to understand
about the economics
but there's a way of business like you
know how how you know sometimes luck you
know
how i get through certain place which is
the best location to buy
that is about learning but how they make
it into game and also computer games as
well
like do you realize that uh it is known
as a lot of these uh
pilots or people who needs a quick
reaction
they will hire people who is very good
reflects
and most of them are gamers so think
about it you know
so if you manage to find someone who's
very active
gamification and everything so i guess
like the
thought process is totally different
right you know
so gamification at the end of the day i
felt it's important
whether it will be like you know five
percent 10
or 100 and
imagining learning something that you
don't feel that you're really reading
through the books and like doing tests
but
more of like you know playing level one
two game uh level three level four level
five
same as like what games are like there
are always like you know
rules that you know you can play this
but better there's a never ending time
game or the game with a
you know finite kind of like you know
rules of who will win but at least you
know that what you always want to do is
be the winner no one's to be a loser in
the game so
give me vacation uh at the end of the
day uh
i truly truly encourage it and
why you know for for us like you know
even learning a skill
like you know uh through apps you know
or better learning like you know how to
use a
fintech app or banking app like you know
taylor or
dbs or like any other banks there's
always this thing called onboarding
you know that you need to learn that
have some kind of sort of elements of
gamification too
and imagining uh recently uh there's an
app on
uh you know spf is on electricity it's
like every day in the check-in you know
to read about tips like how to save
electricity
and you know you just need to follow it
and you get like enough points for it
and you can see
you know with the points your particular
seedling will grow you know from a seed
to sibling to a plant you know
and that is actually element of
gamification and also thinking about
like you know some are apps about for
fitness where people go
exercise it's like you know if you
manage to you know cover up you know
your target
you know steps which is one ten thousand
and
you actually get like you know vouchers
or either like you know card like you
know um
convener like you know airplane ticket
you know or can win like in a
supermarket like you know the whole year
grocery
that is gamification but it makes it
more fun like you know
what is the push factor and
also like you know like imagine that
you're gonna learn about gardening
if there's something like you know a
game that you can do on your mobile and
on
true life so like capturing or each of
the plan that you have like you know the
journey of like you know week by week
you know
and from there maybe you get like
vouchers from like a local nurseries to
buy like
soil or anything that is gamification so
at the end of the day i just want to say
that you know gaming creation is always
on the good side rather than on the
website and
of course you don't want to be someone
who's like you know 24
7 on your like computer playing games
but
try to make daily life a more fun manner
you know
in learning things and last but not
least
um i always live by these two kind of
like sense of like mantra
which is what if and why not what if
it's actually
um the thought of behind like you know
what if we can do something like this
what if my cards can expand it to us
what if if we design more of a different
product other than just playing cards
for people to learn language
so imagine what if it's always open a
big possibility for people to
learn more and why not is the kind of
mentality is like you know you never
subject yourself to like things like
this is done like a to b to c but
you know why not like you know is there
other other ways to try to do something
you know and with that kind of mentality
what if and why not it opens to bigger
possibility and being a person who is a
creative and a creator
this is super important because it
doesn't stops you
from being stagnant and it doesn't stop
you from being like you know
stuck into a a place where you felt that
this is the rule of how we do
create something or we meant something
and i'm gonna follow it a
formula that's been done before so being
adventurous
you know taking risks you know that
actually encompasses into what if and
why not
and after all this i just hope that
everyone is being inspired if not
trying to be inspired to create at least
a product
yeah it might not be the kind of game
changing product like you know
uh kobe 19 vaccine but at least
something
you know that someone can find useful
and also like if it has gamification
element
that'll be great all right all the best
all right thank you lillian for your
insight into using a card game to
improve our learning
i really like that you mentioned wadif
and why not
we hope that this video will give you a
rough idea of when and how to use
gamification in solving problems
we all know the drill by now so once
again a poll should now appear on your
screens
with the question which of these
instances do you think
that gamification could play the biggest
role
which of the listed everyday tasks do
you feel could benefit
most from gamification let us know your
thoughts
all right so by far it seems like most
of us
picked 22 of us in fact picked all of
the other
so i i i suppose we'll see more card
james coming out
all right so we're now moving into the
last segment of the day
which is the q and a section uh section
so if you have not
typed your questions in the q a modules
so please
remember to just type we are taking note
of
all the questions that are coming
through right now all right
and joining us on screen right now
would be yasmin denise
zero and lillian
real people on the screen reporting i'm
so excited by this hi
well thank you all for your insightful
presentations
um we do have a couple of questions
coming in right now
to a panelist there is this question
asking what's the difference between
games and gamification gamification is
basically
you have an existing education system
and then you add game like things into
it like points
or rewards where else a game or what we
call game based learning is whereby you
design
with the learning in mind where the
mechanics and the team has been designed
to learn so
in game you play the game to learn in
gamification
you'll get encouraged to learn because
of the game so that's the difference
yeah yeah and to add on to that as well
like sometimes games have no learning
if you think about when we're a kid and
we play like uh in the streets or we
play with the rocks like sometimes we
just play because we're playing
and that's why games also exist um so
not every game you have to learn uh and
not
and that's why beautification is really
cool is because like it helps you learn
faster and i'm psychologists by
background
so it's just like what it's what they
found if you put like studies
with kids that are gamified and kids who
just have to like learn through learning
the problem is that most learners are
not all they
all are the same like for example i
don't learn by reading
i'm dyslexic so i look at that i'm just
like oh my gosh this is like really
stressful
but somebody else who likes reading
would learn perfectly
but when you gamify you're helping
people who are
kinesthetic like movement based people
who are visual learners
auditory learners combine them together
so you make a much more holistic
experience and when i learned how to
learn visually i went from a b student
to an a student
and it's not because i was a bad student
i never learned how to learn for me
and most of the time we learn because
somebody who is smart
decided this is the way we should all
learn yeah it's quite true
and and also it's like you know how you
put in context like love and loving
is different but it's a very big topic
subject another one is the process of
being
making it so if you were to ask me like
give me fire so you know um there's a
lot of things like if
i'm not sure whether you'll realize like
even when y'all heard about the app for
hpv like you know how they encourage
singaporeans to
lose weight but instead of telling
people hey if you lose weight you know
uh you know you'll be healthy you see so
but what happened is like
funny about the human behavior in
singapore what do people like they like
uh discount they like vouchers but like
free stuff you see
all these kind of things you know that
is the carrot dangling
because of that you know the app has
become quite successful for people like
you know insurance a company wanted to
combine
you know uh airline ticket like sia sq
giving free ticket you know during like
two years ago and people like getting um
ntuc vouchers
you know so that actually making a very
mundane
maybe very boring kind of like situation
to make it much more interesting
where there's always a rewarding system
i guess when we grow up as a child also
for chinese uh family it's always like
if you do your homework we give you five
dollars you know if you like help us to
you know buy something we give you two
dollars so everything that is a
monitoring in exchange that's like a
gamification to us
right we have another question also open
to the floor
how did the internet and social media
change the way people engage with
physical board games
and and as an add-on to that question
and how will kovit 19
further change that dynamic okay i can
answer about the social
because what happened is like uh we
realized like a lot of things
that uh how our games become um
famous in international like us or like
you know in the europe
it's because of collaboration with uh
youtubers who is like you know uh
language learners
and also like gamers so once every time
when they talk about it in a very honest
review because they never receive any
monetary from us
and they never get anything like you
know we are trying to help them to
promote they say that hey i like your
stuff you know i came to singapore i
about it you know i want to
feature you you know are you okay so you
said okay why not you know and you can
chat more about it
and we realize like a lot of times in
this time we cannot um
depend on like you know words of mouth
or just like you know putting it in the
retail and hopefully that someone will
buy it or discover your website
a lot of things to do with social media
like hashtags you know
uh how to know what time to post it you
know for people to find out and you know
the
kind of like truck community when people
example that if they follow hashtag like
board game geeks or board game you know
from there all this will pop up the
algorithm onto your instagram onto your
facebook you know
including like you know when you search
yourself i realize that you know
um because we did a lot of like our
research on google adwords and google
um we realized that every time when we
look for sale refresh is the first one
that
pops up so because maybe it's like you
know back and we have been searching too
much or maybe other people looking it so
organically even up
rather than paying for it so at the end
my conclusion is um collaboration
with another game game designer or
either like you know
influencer or either someone who reviews
stuff and also up the game of social
media of the game of marketing
i think we could take the question on
how he has changed gaming mechanics
because ours was developed during covet
we actually developed the game to be
able to play it on
zoom so if each person has a deck
physically
we actually have two colors of the deck
green and blue
so you imagine you're playing it by your
zoom with your friends you have a
separate set
of instructions and a separate setup to
be able to play
so i'm not sure about all the other
games that have been developed but ours
was developed like specifically because
of this constraint
of not being able to you know meet up in
groups and play
our game is also you know you can play
between two and six people so we also
develop it for small group settings
so as i say can't answer for everybody
else but
specifically because we developed it
during covet we have to take these
constraints into consideration because
so many people were like how do we play
when
you know i come in my friends right so
yeah
yeah um one of the audience members
actually asked
if you could please share some good
advice for local pr
and marketing how do you actually reach
out to the reporters effectively
um so i don't do pr i do i do trainings
around how to become better as a
communicator in general
so what we ended up doing nis and i our
biggest mantra is we don't know
everything we don't know actually most
of the things
but we will know somebody who knows
something
and that's what's actually more
important so for us what we ended up
doing is
reaching out first to our friends to
give us tips and then
denise do you want to share the rest of
it um so specifically for pr
uh so we have friends who are in the pr
industry so they basically help
look to our press release so they're
like what you need to do is come with a
press release
we asked you how to look through it and
because we were we are both sales and
disabled people we actually went to the
sales route where we
we found a list of a thousand media
contacts uh globally and in singapore
like with singapore you can go to the
straight times you know you can look at
the specific forums and you can get your
email addresses right
so we took a thousand emails we put it
into a sales system
where it automates emails and just sends
out all the press releases
to these people uh and we have responses
if they replied or not so we
we started this campaign um to reach out
to as many people as possible but that
was actually not
we got our feature on straight times uh
that was actually true
through a personal contact um so
basically
we we both have been on the news before
and we just reached out to people who
have uh
wrote about us before just pitching this
idea uh we also teach different media
media angles so we went and said okay
let do we do the educational element do
we do the charity element do we do the
virus elements so we had different
angles as well
and we pitched it to different reporters
and we got picked up by one of them so
we did
work for them basically so the key thing
as well to realize is that
like when we were asking our friends for
help they said okay
let's look at where you want to be
featured and i'm like and now it's very
clear straight times it's the biggest
and i want the biggest
and also in singapore to realize if you
get picked up by a smaller
media like the malay or the chinese one
then straight times cannot cover you
so you need to be aware that if you're
going after the small people first
you're never gonna get by straight time
it's like they have a rule
in in this in this world and we didn't
know that so we're like oh that's the
rule
then we know where we're going but also
for example with the straight time
you got to think about it we're not
actually a business thing so it doesn't
make sense for us to be there during the
week
but the sunday times the sunday times is
the
the feel good the inspirational stories
so we were going after people who were
taking care of the sunday times and most
games
will be under the sunday times so if you
don't even have any contacts if you go
through sunday times
they have the emails there so just buy a
sunday time invest that one dollar
and just email them and email people who
have written similar kind of stories
because if someone talks about finance
they will want to cover
debzella no joke right someone talking
about languages and learning and travel
they will want to cover lydian's uh
stuff so you just have to find people
who are
relevant that's why it's like can i have
your contacts and i'm like i don't think
my contact will be your contact
you need to find the contact you need to
have for your angle
because each of us will have a different
angle with our game
that's very interesting i never really
imagined that the publishing industry
actually had this rules in place
yeah so thank you for the insight that
actually we do have a question for
yasmine and denise i think it's from one
of your fans
um she's someone who loves sport games
and she's learning the different
mechanics behind it like the trick
taking
nipple placement etc and she was
wondering
how do you begin with the creation of
the game does it begin
with you choosing the mechanic first or
in the case of baba virus
does it start with the story from your
experience what would you actually
recommend
so this will answer this question but i
want to show you just quickly what it
looks like
so this is our first design that was our
wonderful dynamics of
like the mechanics and then we got
fancier we went to canva
i know we actually did it on like
microsoft microsoft word
and then we had this right we've got an
image from flatacon
and then we did it again a different
shape and then eventually
i hired someone on fiverr and i got this
done and we got it printed
so this will walk you through the
dynamics but the reason why we're
showing this to you
is because there's a lot of that
you don't see
like you're only seeing the final
products but i'm sure with all of our
games
there's so much that you're not
seeing you're only seeing version number
whatever it is so did you want to walk
them through it yeah for sure um so
obviously me and yasmin we are not
really game designers so we went
into it in a very um like kind of a
start-up way where we go
okay first what was the objective of our
game so the first thing we did was okay
we wanted educational and we wanted it
fun
so from there we went on to who is the
target segment of the game
so we were like okay we want to do it
for kids so because of the objective and
target excitement
um we kind of have a generic view where
okay the game has to be level zero it
has to be east
and what we did was we went to do
research on level zero games
like oh denise i think you should
explain to them about level zero because
everyone will know the level zero games
on board game geek yeah so
i'm actually not very that family i just
know that level 0 is like super easy to
get you have to play the mechanics are
really easy so you have different levels
for different types of games
um i'm sure like stills game is much
higher level than our game
because it's targeted at a different
segment so i was we wanted it easy
so from there we went to look at the
competitors saying okay what are the
really easy games are really popular
and we use it as inspiration so for
example you know we looked at sushi go
we looked at exploding kittens we look
at guns and robbers
so we took a few of the really the games
that we really liked and we mapped our
education element
into their game mechanics so basically
we said okay
sushi goes a point system so let us try
to make this education thing with a
point system
exploding cadence is a you know a
cheating a stealing system let's do that
too so basically we had new version one
two three i think we did six versions in
the first one of uh
using different competitors and putting
our educational element in there and we
met it there
and then we tested it out uh and then we
realized just because sushi go exploding
cadence is fun
might not mean our version is fun
because it was so boring the first time
we had held the test
so we asked a lot of feedback on what
was missing in these games so
you tested out six we chose three um
game mechanics in the end
and then we tested them out and then we
asked friends hey why is this so
boring
um and then we had two main things we
thought about how do we make it more fun
and how do we make it more educational
so some ideas that came out on how to
make it more fun we had friends who were
like
what you need something that up
the game you need a card that allows
people to
stop people from winning if not it's too
it's too simple or you need people to
you need to add interactive elements
like physical things like jumping jacks
or stuff like that to make it more fun
if not it's really boring
as well so we added a lot of elements
based on feedback from our friends
and then the second part was after we
made it fun
and we can sit through it playing for
like three hours we're like okay now how
do we make it
educational because that was the main
objective right
and then we change the design and some
instructions to force people to remember
stuff so for example
part of our game is for you to remember
what protective items are
for kids and then we realized through
the game
people were not remembering them so we
added a new card where
you have to remember them if not you get
your card stolen so we did a lot of
things
to make it more educational and then
after it became fun and educational the
last thing we did was how do you make
the game balanced
so you know in terms of the number of
cards to make it make sure that
everybody
you know the game doesn't end in five
minutes or it doesn't take 40 minutes to
to end and also how do we make it
balanced for two to three people playing
versus four to six people playing so all
these things
it just came out as we were playing the
game that we didn't know about and he
just you know
went step by step uh how to fix it and
then
probably should probably like write this
for you and share this with you the
steps you have an idea
um but that's our way of doing that's
our way
all right so i'm just gonna take one
more question from the audience and this
last question is actually open to the
floor
um from your experiences how would you
see
locally designed games differing from
the other games around the world
do singaporean games have a certain
flavor to them
what are your thoughts on the local
design industry
um okay i'm happy to answer because i'm
a massive gamer
i think it really depends on who your
market is so
like games like singapore dreams are
targeted very much
everyone knows this is for singapore um
i think it's also like
in terms of how much and how big your
ambition is like i love
the way that lydian put it like the what
if and why not
and if you're just saying like because
initially we're not gonna lie denise and
i our goal is to sell 100 decks we're
like it's 100 decks
we're awesome and then we realized
actually this is really fun
like what if we sell more and now we've
sold 1500 decks and now we're realizing
what if we sell 10 000 decks and what if
we impact more lives so
i think it's just about realizing that
the singapore market isn't that big
so if you want to go beyond that we have
to look at other opportunities and i
already can hear from
lydia and zou that they're talking to
europe and the us and that's because
like
if you're if your problem is big enough
to what's happening contextually like
language or business or
or hygiene you can go at a different
angle but if you make a very local game
a hyper local game
then you got to realize that the market
size conversion
it you've got to know your numbers a
little bit to understand
i'll take over for the local game so we
created singlish because you know
um there actually there was a guy from
the panel you know uh when we presented
he was asking like hey i've been living
in singapore for a few years
do you have singlish card games and
without thought we created that and we
realized that you know
um a lot of tories or people who just
settled in in singapore which
singapore is like you know a hub for
everyone you know from international to
come here to visit or either to work you
know
and they would like to you know be close
to what is the local culture is see so
they got a singlish card
contract and for the singapore food cut
game it's also the same kind of like uh
uh thing so we're designing both
thoughts of like you know local people
and also people who come to visit
singapore or come to work in singapore
the local people is the more of like you
know hey how much do you know about your
singapore food or like what to eat you
know for lunch you know and they can
make it as a game for that
and for the people from overseas it's
like no oh
it's singapore food just chicken rice or
or chili crab you see but
before or more than that kind of like
dishes for that for people to discover
and thinking about like you know games
for a longer run
other languages like cantonese hopkins
which actually has a lot of interest
from overseas
like especially when i posted one of my
posts in uh subtle cantonese trades you
know
it was crazy you know everyone from like
you can see like where the cantonese are
actually based in u.s is always in the
west coast of east coast new york
uh california so they have a lot of big
sales from there and also like uh big
cities in europe like you know london
you know amsterdam is everywhere that is
chinatown canada
cantonese people will be there so that
that is how we plan it and
of course like you know uh it's a good
thing to design a game you know for fun
or fashion project or what you think but
i think
at the end of day what is your you know
end goal do you want to earn money from
it or do you
just want to have it like you know to
showcase that you design a product and
that's all
first it felt like after a while you're
thinking the infinite mindset
mindset where we think like okay for all
the energy that we are putting in
you know we need something a reward not
just a reward of like you know being
appearing on like you know social media
everything
a rewards like you know monetary rewards
so that we can create more games you see
yeah
thank you very much panellings i think
for the engaging conversation
and to our audience thank you for all
the excellent questions coming through
um don't worry we'll try to address as
much of the questions as we can
post event um we hope that you have
gained some useful tips for today's
session
and if you would like to find out more
about what is design as well as
national vending gallery and ongoing
exhibition
at the national design center please
scan the respective qr codes on your
screen
now and
the national bending gallery is an
experimental crossbreed of a design
showcase
select shop and automated retail the
national wedding gallery supplies
merchandise assembled into topics that
reveal the manifold influence of design
grouping of lives
so it is currently showcasing its maiden
topic
cardboard which features 18 locally
designed tabletop games
including the games designed by the
speakers today so it's really amazing
how these
logo designers are able to transform a
ubiquitous material like cardboard
to imaginative gameplays fit for social
and experiential
learning so be sure to pop by national
design center to
experience the exhibit first hand we
would like to hear your feedback on the
session as well
so please help us with a quick post
event survey by scanning the leftmost qr
code
the first event surveillance can also be
found in the zoom chat
if you would like to find out more about
the programs the national design center
has lined up
under the theme of singapore our home
scan the qr code that you see on the
right
with that say we hope you enjoyed
today's webinar
we would like to thank you for joining
us this afternoon
and our wonderful speakers and guests as
well should you wish to
visit today's discussion a summary of
keynotes will be shared with you via
email along with the relevant links on
how
you can find out more about our speakers
and actually get in contact with them
so we hope you have found the session
inspiring and meaningful
and we hope to see you again at our
subsequent events thank you for joining
us today we will be closing today's
session
and have a great week i hate guys